foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
actor comedian producer former Saturday
Night Live cast member
and now champion
Will Ferrell joining us champ I like it
I like it
congratulations congratulations
did you cry
uh I cried multiple times yeah there's a
lot of Tears partly because I
kept spilling my beer okay but uh no a
lot of exhausting
overtime game into
penalty kicks
Christian Bale the power of the man bun
coming through
in the I don't know what last minute of
extra time it was crazy yeah yeah MLS
champ just to let you know lafc and you
got a lot of celebrity friends fans who
showed up there uh give us an idea who
was on the guest list sure uh uh Magic
Johnson was there uh your good friend
Justin Bieber yep
um uh you're tight I know you're tight
with jbeebs Dan yeah
we had a Wiz Khalifa of course of course
when you think soccer
you think Wiz Khalifa
um and uh Mia ham you know is part of
the ownership group uh Nomar uh uh yeah
it was a a Sia is a regular fan oh she
wears an entirely gold dress okay every
game because we're black and gold our
colors okay but when you started this
first of all how did you start it and
and what were your expectations
I I was kind of brought into the group
uh from uh literally one of the the main
Partners we were uh dads at the same
school and we would always we'd talk
soccer in the morning at you know drop
off with the kids and
he had sent me an email saying give me a
call there's something you know I think
you might be really interested in being
involved with and they talked about how
they're starting a second MLS team
in Los Angeles uh obviously the galaxy
has been around for a while uh and that
but the trick the thing was they're
going to build a soccer only Stadium
just outside of downtown L.A uh and I
thought oh that's going to be the key
right there and and they were going to
be
uh it was going to be what we would
consider more of a modern
state-of-the-art state with with food
and beverage and restaurants and
Hospitality Suites and all the stuff
that a lot of the MLS stadiums uh didn't
really have so all of that coming
together
uh I thought oh I'll totally be involved
with this what do you get as a owner for
winning the championship uh
I don't know I don't know as of yet I
don't know if I
I got to drink out of the cup yeah what
was in the cup what was in there
I think there's probably some beer and
champagne
Maybe
the sweat of Wiz Khalifa
are you thinking about maybe playing a
couple of minutes one time let's say
you're up seven nil as we like to say in
soccer and yes and you could you insert
yourself
as the owner into the game
I would have to look at the bylaws
signed to a contract right I couldn't
just run down on the field yeah uh so
maybe yeah maybe there's some sort of
you know
Pro I don't know kind of provisionary
contract where I could at any point if
needed
uh run onto the field for a two-minute
spurt yeah yeah you know sometimes
there's the emergency goalie in hockey
and they get somebody out of the stands
or equipment guy
that's that would be the model I would
love that yeah uh by the way the full
introduction uh Will Ferrell and Ryan
Reynolds have a new movie it's a
Christmas movie called spirited and it
uh premieres in theaters today what a
coincidence we're having you on and the
movie comes out today it's great timing
wow okay you guys are so good at that uh
it's in theaters today and uh streaming
on Apple TV plus next Friday November
18th
this feels it's a musical it is we're we
it's full on singing and dancing uh
there was uh
I'm I'm I think you'll be proud of me
Dan I really I really went for it this
time well let me hear you say not my
usual laid-back self I went for it okay
okay yeah because you're usually very
subtle
I mean usually yeah I'm
the master of subtlety but then you
start in musical theater
I never did any of that stuff I didn't I
didn't even I didn't begin even acting
till after college so uh so this was
yeah this was a huge step up this is
like serious songs written by uh pasok
and Paul who did the music for La La
Land and greatest showman and uh so when
they presented the demos of the songs
Ryan and I were were clear like you know
we we can carry a tune but but don't
make it too hard and then they wrote
these songs that were incredibly complex
it was like you guys what are you doing
how are we going to do this and they're
like don't worry we're gonna coach you
up and you guys will you guys will do it
and and it's uh it it came out really
good I'm very proud of it is there going
to be kind of a Bradley Cooper a
stars-born feel to your performance here
uh I'm not gonna lie to you no there
won't be that
um there was I did read one review that
said uh this one kind of emotional
number I had said it was it was uh Josh
grobanesque wow so I got that okay I
didn't think you read reviews I don't
usually I just got sent it from a friend
who said hey this one was kind of nice
give me the worst review
that you remember on one of your best
movies or one of your most popular ones
I do
if I it's happened a number of times
for movies that were I mean what the
classic one was Step Brothers
and I think it was Roger Ebert who said
I'm begging you all of this anyone
reading this do not see this movie do
not buy it on DVD do not support this
type of filmmaking this basically the
end of Western Civilization Paulie do
you have the review I absolutely do and
Will's quoting it almost verbatim well
he begs people not to see the movie like
like a personal favor how do does that
not hurt
well we had once once they reached
critical mass on the positive side then
you can as a treat dive into the
negative ones uh because you realize
those are just outliers so it doesn't
hurt when it you know The Ledger is
higher on the more positive side but I
did one of the crazier reviews though I
was reading a review of of Corel Steve
Carell when he did 40 Year Old Virgin
and I thought oh Steve's a buddy I I
remember I remember him talking about
this premise on the set of Anchorman and
that sounded like what such a funny
movie I thought oh here's the review I
want to read
the reviewer goes out of her way to cite
me in the first two paragraphs of how
much she hates me
his movie would be similar she's like it
was not anything
it's so good
so you you made him look better because
the movie didn't resemble anything you
would do and I'm yes and I'm not in 40
year old virgin at all but she dedicates
the top two paragraphs to how much she
can't stand anything I did I do so that
was that was a classic
but a lot of people say they don't read
reviews yeah no I and I I truly don't
for the most part
does your wife read them and then says
you don't want to hear this one
yeah she'll peruse it yeah yeah and
she'll go yeah uh how do you hang around
Ryan Reynolds without laughing like when
you're doing these scenes it just feels
like are you guys ever honest with each
other like real people to each other or
you're Will Ferrell he's Ryan Reynolds
your celebrities
no I mean that was that was kind of the
the great part of working with Ryan and
not having worked with them before we we
both enjoy kind of you know off-camera
really kind of having dare I say
heartfelt conversations about family and
life and and that sort of thing oh but
at the same time we we loved uh we love
doing the bits on set so it was a good
it was a it was good but he's like yeah
he's devastatingly quick fun bright guy
uh the movie The Christmas movie
spirited premieres and theaters today
start streaming on Apple TV plus that's
next Friday it's Will Ferrell and Ryan
Reynolds the Dan antich have a question
if uh you would indulge them you know
what though Dan we've got to I I have
more information on the Dublin trip
we're still planning on going right
yes late August I'd like to go when navy
plays Notre Dame yes
I talked to NBC
okay I think that uh and I'd like to
maybe open this up to our audience maybe
we could have a group because it's go
with us it's become it's become similar
to the storyline in Old School where we
start a fraternity obviously I'm getting
like dads at my school coming up to me
in the parking lot hey is that uh
you really going to Dublin like no wives
is that is that uh did I get in on that
yep uh so that's starting to happen
number one number two
if I if if I remember correctly the you
guys had on your short list of other
celebrities that you'd like to show up
one Jennifer Garner yeah
turns out she's a mom at our school
so I've got to try to make contact to
recruit her I think
what if you just ran into her car
accidentally
and then you trade information
great that's it
yeah just so anyway okay so the damage
have a question who wants to go first
here on Todd Todd Fritz he's going to go
first your question for Wilfred okay I'm
looking at a bio from Britannica says
Pharaoh grew up in Suburban Irvine where
he played varsity football and Drew
laughs for reading the high school's
morning announcements in a variety of
voices I want to know is that true and
what was your favorite voice had you
come up with those characters for your
high school comedy
oh that that that was all true uh uh I
probably I don't know the the various
voices is a little
that's a bit of a stretch I think I did
an Irish accent once making fun of like
Irish Spring soap commercial hmm you
guys remember Irish Spring yes I do
fresh and clean as a whistle yeah
you're as strong as an ax
by the way is that a hotel room you're
in
uh yeah I'm in a hotel room yeah
hey
I live and I usually I live in a hotel
yeah I only live uh weekends are up at
the home with the family
uh Satan what's your question for uh
Will Ferrell hello when you were say
like 12 years old what was the funniest
movie you'd ever seen or what was what
was your uh like sense of humor there
what was just the the movie that you
were like this is the best
12 years old maybe 15.
yeah I'm
I'm gonna probably say roughly in that
zone uh um
48 Hours Nick Nolte Eddie Murphy
okay
yeah and and pro and Animal House kind
of blew my mind yeah
you made it Eddie Murphy
I've met him once
was that he
it was great we only said a couple but
he's he's thought I was funny so I'll
take it
yeah uh Mark could have been lying to me
he could have yeah yeah but did you say
do you think I'm funny like did you make
it okay
oh my God Eddie Murphy do you think yeah
so it felt like he was obligated to say
and he he went yeah I guess so Mars Marv
your question for willfare is there a
movie that you passed up on that
sometimes you just like damn I wish I
would have taken that so
there is there is a movie uh that that I
I kind of semi-passed on but I ended up
being in it and it still benefited me
but uh originally Vince asked me to do
Owen's part in Wedding Crashers
and I
I was like I don't know I didn't I I
frankly didn't think the other part was
as good as his
and uh
and then but then they called me to do
the meatloaf guy I came up with all that
Meatloaf stuff so it's still but but
yeah that was one where I was like oh
that I don't know what I was thinking on
that one even though Owen's very good
but what so you said you came up with
your lines when you're Chas your the
media yeah a lot of that yelling back at
the mom and I don't know what she does
back there and that was just I just kind
of riffed that day now do you make that
agreement with Will where or you make
that with Vince where you go hey can I
just come up with my lines and then he
goes all right go off and play in the
sandbox oh they yeah I mean
any we were all there was that stretch
there we all did cameos in each other's
films and that was that was the everyone
had the green light to just please do
whatever you want to do and we'll sort
it out later so that was just an
unspoken rule between all of us did you
get to keep the car as Frank the Tank is
that something that you would ask the
red dragon yeah
I didn't think to ask about it okay but
I do have I think I wore them into uh
you wore the shoes or the green shoes I
have those yeah I've seen those yeah
I've seen those but I didn't know if you
got the car I would have been too afraid
to ask for something like that yeah
because Kevin Costner
got the Mustang in Bull Durham that he I
thought you would say Kevin Costner kept
some of the horses from dances before
he kept two of them two yeah two of them
uh Paulie your question for willfare
well I've read that during SNL Lauren
Michaels the executive producer really
doesn't like it when cast members break
character or laugh at each other stuff
how hard is that to not do and did it
happen to you did it happen to others
how big of a deal was that at SNL
that I don't remember I don't remember
being such a big deal but it was It was
kind of it was kind of the
the unwritten rule like you tried not to
break but
I loved trying to capsize everyone else
so that was uh
there was a sketch that Rachel Dratch
and I used to do this these the lovers
sketch we were always in a hot tub and
act where these weird professors who
were overly sexual and uh I had a break
there because I had a huge beard so I
could laugh and hide it underneath this
beard uh uh but I was always going after
Jimmy Fallon or whoever the guest post
was to try to get the Fallon
everybody gets Fallon that's it yeah
that's it that's day one stuff there
I don't remember anyone being
reprimanded like stop cracking up
do you miss that though this that
improvisational or the live part of it I
mean that that that's as close as you
get to doing theater
I miss it sometimes I don't I you miss
it more right when you have left the
show but
the times that I've come back to host I
realize oh this is uh
you you definitely have to have you
don't have to be in shape with how
quickly that show moves and and the
hours and the and uh
um
yeah the last time I hosted I was like
how did I ever do that I don't remember
how I ever did this before
well the hours you can't have a family
and yeah
I don't know how people stay on it for
as long as they do or have
it's you know you get a lot of you get
the whole summer off you get it's one of
the few kind of jobs in New York if you
want to live in New York so I think you
weigh those you weigh those things
well uh good luck with the movie uh
spirited premieres in theaters today
it's uh Will Ferrell and Ryan Reynolds
actually feels like it's Ryan Reynolds
and Will Ferrell
well I mean you kind of you should do it
alphabetical Will Ferrell Ryan Reynolds
okay
but if I had Ryan Reynolds on then I'd
have to go Ryan Reynolds and Will
Ferrell he probably should keep it
alphabetical and and good luck with uh
you know Jennifer Garner it's not
Gardner as you you had her name wrong
the last time you were on Jennifer
gardener Gardener yeah and just a fender
bender and say hi ah I'm so sorry I'd
like to make it up to you would you like
to go to Dublin with me and uh a hundred
guys at the end of August
who could pass that up perfect
and that sounds like a movie you and
Jennifer Gardner Gardner yeah and you go
to Dublin after a fender bender
done and done and live happily ever
after shoot it all in Ireland yeah okay
got it I'm gonna be in touch because we
will we will plan this and we've got my
marching orders now yes and if if Paul
Rudd wants to join us he can well we can
get red for sure Wiz Khalifa
okay
that will be no no if we need to spark
up we can spark up uh Justin Bieber
yep Biebs could join us magic let's see
if magic wants to yeah but you know go
through your Rolodex here yeah Ryan
Reynolds
oh Ryan would Ryan would have a great
time you'd have a lovely time he could
hop over
after visiting rexham wrexham yeah yeah
I like this this is this is
metastasizing exactly that's the right
term that's the right term good luck
with the movie okay thanks Dan Champion
Will Ferrell hashtag champion
right word